[Musique]
qui pourrait prétendre aujourd'hui que
l'algérie n'entendait plus l'appel de la
mer depuis la libération combien d'un
jeune africain sont venus chercher le
début d'une carrière à l'école des
mousses de lapérouse l'un interne
allemands et les européens et musulmans
perez est chiche 4,10 à l'ombre des
trois couleurs des heures laborieuse et
profitable l'école des mousses de
lapérouse destiné à former des équipes à
bhl d'élite tonneaux à l'air matelots
qu'elle abrite une formation aussi
complète que varié où les sports de base
deviennent une place éminente
[Musique]
le monde
on n'a pas oublié ici entre les sports
et malgré la transformation qu'ont subis
les navires depuis la disparition de la
marine en bois
l'école du gabier cette voltige de rose
classe ce ballet aérien parmi les zergs
et les cordages
cette gymnastique de se situe
harmonieusement entre les cours
d'instruction générale et les exercices
pratiques du métier de marin
[Musique]
tous ces cours s'inscrivent dans un
horaire où les sports les jeux et les
soins les plus divers ont leur place il
serait absurde comme marin ignora la
natation ligne à l'heure du bain et ce
n'est pas la moins appréciée
[Musique]
il serait inconcevable comme marin ne
soit pas impeccable il ya le jour de
l'investiture
[Musique]
il serait ridicule que l'ancienne armée
matelotage soit oubliée même dans un
temps où les cordages non plus sur les
navires d'aujourd'hui l'importance
qu'ils mesurent naguère et l'on apprend
toujours l'art pittoresque et curieux
qui permet aux marins de n'être jamais
embarrassé lorsqu'il dispose d'un cil
[Musique]
or
hamon
une école de la paire aux normes des
matelots environ autres aviron un
musulman et jeunes français six coups
droits dans une fraternité accentuer
encore par celle de la vie de
l'éducation et de l'effort
pour une jeunesse unie instruite ici
pour créer une part de l'avenir une part
de cet avenir ou sous les plis du même
drapeau la france et l'algérie
marcheront côte à côte
[Musique]
gerba est peut être la perle de la
police dans le golfe de gabès à 15 cents
mètres seulement de la codp djerba ali
le merveilleuse des lotophages que
chanson onair est la patrie des
tisserands et des potiers qui vivent à
l'ombre de ses 286 mosquée là avec la
laine des troupeaux un peuple de deux
mille artisans qui selon les techniques
ancestrales
ces belles couvertures de djerba dont la
réputation a dépassé depuis des siècles
les limites de la tunisie ici depuis les
âges les plus reculés les méthodes
artisanales n'ont pas changé l'atelier
du tisserin garde le même pittoresque
qu'on vieux dans le métier reste celui
d'autrefois
il y à ici une tradition artisanale et
puissante qui a fixé une fois pour
toutes dans le sens du travail et de la
qualité de loubards
[Musique]
oui
auprès des tisserands et mais les a eux
les potiers de djerba au sillon d'une
vieille tradition le travail
en même temps quand renom séculaire
c'est à eux qu'on doit depuis le xème
siècle peut être ses poteries rustique
aux formes cependant gracieuse répandu
dans tout le bassin méditerranéen
la technique primitive n'a pour
instrument que le tour et le four elle a
en plus le métier est pourrait-on dire
l'art de ses potiers successeur de
génération de potiers qui leur ont
transmis avec leurs secrets de
fabrication
l'amour du bel ouvrage et de la pièce
réussi
[Musique]
l'oeuvre de la france tutélaire dans ce
petit domaine de lindre et de l'économie
tunisienne
plus certainement efficace sinon
apparente
on lui doit certainement la protection
et la conservation de ces anti formule
artisanale qui firent leur nom de djerba
et dont la disparition dans un instinct
juste riz standardisés utt du point de
vue national et de points de vue
culturel une lourde perte
[Musique]
djerba continue et continuera à vivre
entre ces tisserands et ses potiers
exportant les produits de cette
industrie qui est déjà peut être au
temps des romains répondait en
méditerranée leur nom de l'île aux
sables d'or
un peu plus chaque jour un rythme
régulier et sur le néant cas point
d'équipement qui fera de lui l'une des
terres les plus riches et les mieux
organisés de toute la sec le bas rhin
jeudi une faute sur l'humeur est bien le
plus grand plein marocain mais dont le
débit régulier est rusé naguère
considérablement l'importance commence à
développer à la fois des possibilités
industriels et agricoles du pays
construit pendant la guerre au prix
d'énormes difficultés
il favorise grâce à l'augmentation de la
production électrique qui permet
l'enrichissement industriels
pendant que grâce aux canalisations
diverses qui l'alimentent il féconde les
plaines naguère désolé du béni amir est
née entre up à la culture
déjà dans cette plaine 15 mille hectares
de coton ont été mis en culture et les
premières récoltes se sont montrés
particulièrement prometteuse grâce à ces
nouvelles possibilités de prospérité
fait par l'oeuvre française la tribu des
beni and ear force de 60me dame dont la
sécheresse et les razzias d'autrefois
avait une tribu pauvres et semi nomades
à retrouver une vie normale sur la terre
des ancêtres fixer désormais sur un sol
enrichi et perfidie et parlons les béni
amir au milieu de leurs champs irrigués
par 1000 km de canalisations sont
maintenant en route vers une prospérité
de bon aloi avant 1948 il se trouve en
possession de 45 mille hectares irrigués
dont la récolte pourra rivaliser en
qualité avec le meilleur coton d'égypte
[Musique]
mais à ces soins qui engage l'avenir la
france malgré ces difficultés ne réduit
pas son oeuvre
le port de casablanca des charges chaque
jour les envois de blé que fait la
métropole au maroc
victime d'une sécheresse pelle qu'on en
vit pas depuis un demi siècle
[Musique]
un dos de chameau jusqu'aux villages les
plus éloignés le sud marocain
ce blé ira chasser la famine menace ans
[Musique]
e
on sait dans ces villages du sud ce que
sont les fans in autrefois une 7ème
fréquenté meurtrière les populations des
villages ont encore des souvenirs que
ces époques terrible dont la sollicitude
française but d'éviter le retour et l'on
conçoit qu'en conséquence la joie qu
apporte aujourd'hui à ces peuples n'a
guère éprouvé l'arrivée des caravanes du
blé l'inoubliable bienfaits de la france
[Musique]
m
défense au désert infini le tafilalet
marocain est lui même qu'un désert
allait-il abandonnés à leur sort
misérable les terres et les populations
de cette inhospitalière contrer la
france ne l'a pas voulu
pour lutter contre les épidémies que la
négligence et le manque de soins rendait
inéluctable elle a d'abord envoyé
premier ambassadeur les messagers de la
santé et prévenant la maladie dans les
centres les plus retirés les missions
médicales ont d'abord fait reculer la
mort qui menaçait une rame les oasis et
terreur partant les troupeaux masse les
cultures [ __ ]
[Musique]
il fallait donner à ces populations les
moyens de s'attacher à leur sol il
fallait leur assurer des possibilités de
mener leur vie sans crainte des famines
comme sans craindre des épidémies
c'est ce qu'à leur tour les ingénieurs
français ont tenté victorieusement à la
recherche et à la découverte des sources
ont succédé les travaux de réception et
de distribution de l'eau
[Musique]
lever de pierre barrage grossier fossés
etc à noémie tiff
on sait place peu à peu à des ouvrages
d'art dont l'importance et la qualité
seront les garants d'une prospérité
chaque jour plus sûr et plus étendue
[Musique]
assurer la santé a assuré la vie
quotidienne ce sont les deux bases
essentielles de l'existence d'un peuple
mais la france ne borne pas là son rôle
elle a voulu elle veut que les
populations du tafilalet bénéficie d'une
instruction qui déplaceront au niveau
des populations plus favorisés des
écoles se sont bâtis des classes se sont
ouverts
[Musique]
l'instruction complétée par une
éducation manuel approprié dans laquelle
chaque outil trouve sa place lalime
comme leurs impôts leurs impôts comme la
bêche vin coulait sur le tafilalet comme
l'eau génératrice de vie
[Musique]
et nous verrons un jour grâce à l'oeuvre
française le tafilalet dr pierre devenir
comme ses autres régions marocaines
revivifier une terre heureuse prospère
et fortunés
[Musique]
au lendemain de la guerre qui était
encore l'effort de tunisie des amas de
ferraille vestiges de bateau perdu des
quais dénonce les des passes dangereuses
des zones détruites
tout était parfait
[Musique]
1 le confort des phosphates le grand
port de l'huile s'est rapidement mise au
travail les plans de reconstruction de
la ville et du port s'exécute
des améliorations seront apportées aux
anciennes constructions endommagées et
fax pourra reprendre plus grande encore
la place éminente qu'elle occupe dans
les échanges tunisien a déjà sorti de
ses ruines retrouve dès maintenant avec
le connaissent de l'alfa une partie de
son animation d'antan
[Musique]
dans tous les dommages ont également été
considérés mais la vo de reconstruction
entreprise vigoureusement rendra bientôt
à sousse toutes ses chances de
prospérité les épaves encore présentes
disparaîtront les digues seront
reconstitués et déjà sur les chantiers
on reprend le travail
[Musique]
b
sousse blessés se reprend à vivre et
parmi les ports tunisiens sous ce ne
sera pas la dernière a retrouvé
l'activité passée
[Musique]
je
devant tunis la goulette était encombrée
des débris de la bataille des carcasses
dangereuse pour la navigation gênait son
libre accès aussi ses forces ton de
libérer complètement la goulette de ces
épaves de fer qui sont autant d'écueils
[Applaudissements]
amené à la rive ces carcasses
disparaîtront sous la main fait le
chalumeau et s'en iront alimenter les
fonderies tir front de ferraille l'acier
deux nouveaux navires
[Musique]
et
quant au fort de tunis il retrouve son
activité chaque jour de nombreux navires
venus de partout qui déchargent les
produits dont andrey tunisie
établissement ce vaste courant des
changes qui coulait en double sens
autant de l'avant-guerre punissent est
dès aujourd'hui un porc vivant dont la
vie ne pourra que s'amplifier
[Musique]
et
et nous pouvons voir la promesse d'une
résurrection total de l'activité
d'efforts remise à neuf dans ces navires
déjà à quai dans ce far qui appelle en
mai
[Musique]
dans ses tifs rendu aucun loup travail à
la fin française dans sétif où se sont
passées les traces des regrettables
incidents de l'an dernier le gouverneur
général yves chataigneau est venu
montrer que rien ne subsiste dans
l'esprit français de ce qui fut l'erreur
d'une journée des types de puits a vu
grandir l'oeuvre française
c'est ce qu'a constaté le gouverneur en
visitant l'école professionnelle ou les
jeunes musulmans s'applique à la
connaissance des techniques modernes
c'est ce qu'il a constaté aussi en
visitant l'hôpital de sétif et en idées
coran une infirmière musulmane
demoiselle messai se distingua
particulièrement lors du tremblement de
terre ou au delà gouverneur général a
rendu hommage à l'esprit de fraternité
c'est de cet esprit que témoigne
l'hôpital de ces types le plus beau et
le plus moderne de toute l'algérie
l'hôpital s'ouvre à tous commencé en
1936 terminé en 1939 il comporte pour
ses 400 lits tous les aménagements
inventé et mis au point par les
techniques les plus avancées celui qui
autrefois n'avait de ressources que dans
la science du marabout ou les sortilèges
du guérisseur vient maintenant de loin
assuré qu'il est de trouver à l'hôpital
de sétif les véritables soins la
véritable science qui feront fuir la
maladie
[Musique]
oui
un bloc opératoire très complet plein ce
capital de sétif sur le plan des plus
beaux hôpitaux des grandes villes
modernes
et l'activité radio munich sous toutes
ses formes est couramment utilisée ici
comme elle peut l'être à paris ou à new
york
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hôpital de sétif ne serait pas complet
s'il ne comportait une maternité
magnifiquement organisé cette maternité
existe ou côtes à côtes européennes et
musulmanes se retrouvent unis parce que
l'humanité a de plus fort et de plus
touchant la maternité l'hôpital de sétif
et surtout un témoignage le témoignage
indiscutable de l'oeuvre française
poursuivie en dépit de tous les orages
en faveur d'une terre et d'une
population à qui la france a tant
apporté
[Musique]
à